Canadians are allowed to drive in the
United States onvalid Canadian licenses
so when I got pulled over right after he
had finished his ticket I took the
audience to the Beverly Hills Police
Department and went and filed a full on
complaint against officer Pena and I had
a very professional nice officer at the
department walked me through and worked
through that process with me on camera
so you can watch from start to end but
yeah they dismissed the ticket the best
part of that whole story is Guess How
many more times officer Pena bugged me
after that probably none zero not up
front plate ticket ever not a exhaust
ticket ever and I saw him loss after
that